so are black americans the new forgotten
americans under president joe biden here
to respond is virginia lieutenant
governor elect winston sears uh winston
uh sears thanks so much for joining us
congratulations on your historic
election
we saw this was to happen right
yes we did and we've been talking about
it when we were on the campaign trail
that in virginia we've been losing jobs
as a matter of fact to our neighboring
states
in fact i just saw that i think it was
two weeks ago that the toyota plant is
going to be going to north carolina with
all the jobs that
come with it of course about three or
four months ago
ford is going to be building a plant and
fort f-150 pickup truck plant it's a six
mile long plant they're going to be
building in tennessee so virginia lost
that but we're not going to be losing
jobs anymore
we have a new administration coming in
we're going to get rid of certain
business regulations that are keeping
businesses from coming here we're going
to protect our right to work in fact we
were about one vote away from losing
that in the state uh in the senate and
so with the new administration glenn
younkin's administration we're going to
be improving our job status here
you know i i just got to ask you you
know we had a whole presidential
campaign and it seemed like there was
such a emphasis on tone and an emotion
no one really took the the time in the
media to look at the numbers and black
folks were doing well i mean even the
brothers that i talked with in harlem
talk about how they were able to great
their businesses and they got their
llc's aligned that was an actual
conversation about progress and black
america but it seems like we're going
back in time right now
well when you had governors uh deciding
that certain businesses were essential
and others weren't mostly mom and pops
suffered and in the meantime the big box
stores stayed open and then when you
have uh you've got to stay home with
your child because the governor's closed
the schools and yet it's interesting to
me that private schools were able to
figure out very quickly how to keep
open while
covid was raging and so the public
schools were closed but the private
schools were open
and people had to stay home with the
children and so there we go you know
businesses suffered you know policy is a
darn thing and if you're not careful you
can destroy a whole economy and by the
way suddenly they figured out inflation
does exist it's not in our minds gas has
gone up thank you very much you closed
the pipeline your first day in office
president biden and the food has gone up
we are paying more
you wonder what what are they not
getting
you know lieutenant governor elect i've
been impressed with you especially with
you being able to talk with all
different people and going out there in
in the community and you talked about
policy we've seen policy from the
democratic party they want to let felons
back out people that are a risk to
society but you did something special
you went and visited your constituent in
the prison you said something that i
thought was powerful you said that
they can't come out here but you can
come and visit them there what did you
mean by that
well i'm lieutenant governor elect and
i'm going to be sworn in next week as
the newest lieutenant governor and
people in the prison are my constituents
and they can't come to me so i have to
go to them and see what's going on in
their world what are their needs and i
want to make sure that i also talk with
the department of corrections officials
you know to find out what do they need
as well and so that's why i went i am a
former homeless shelter director and i
have been a prison ministry leader for
two years i went to a men's prison
every wednesday six o'clock i gave the
message of hope and
it blessed me to bless them so i was at
some brides correctional facility out in
chesapeake and you might see this little
thing that they made for me they're
learning
so that they can be better than when
they
went in and so they're learning
electrical skills plumbing skills
they're learning autocad they're
learning so many different things if
they don't have a ged and they want a
ged they can get it you know we need to
encourage more of this why because we
don't want them to leave the same way
that they came in we want them to be
productive members of society we want
them to be the mommies and daddies that
their families need
we don't want to keep paying
about thirty two thousand dollars per
inmate per year to house them no we've
got to make sure that they're much
better than when they went in you know
virginia
is a mess right now but it looks like
help is on the way lieutenant governor
elect thanks so much for joining me
tonight